(upbeat piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(uptempo music)
(upbeat music)
- Well you all remembered
to come here today
and you all remembered how to get here.
And you all have plans
for what you're gonna do
after this meeting is over later today
because that's what it's all about.
Our world is a world of memories
and we are our memories.
And we think about memory
often about the past,
but memory is really about the future
because it enables us to use
information that you gain
in order to get along in life,
and that's what it's all about.
Well, I'm gonna talk about some people
for whom the future is
not terribly important
but the past is awfully
important, unusual people indeed.
So here's the question of
the very famous psychologist,
maybe the founder of modern
psychology, William James.
He said, "Of some experiences
"no memory survives the
instance of their passage.
"Of others, it is confined to
a few moments, hours or days.
"Others may be recalled
as long as life endures.
"Can we explain these differences?"
Why is it that you can remember right now
exactly what I said,
even with the intonation,
you could mimic me,
and tomorrow, you're gonna
remember that there was a meeting
that you came to and you're gonna
(audience laughs)
remember a few elements.
Well, I'm gonna...
It's not like that for all people.
There was a man named Daniel McCartney
about whom an article was published
in the Journal of Speculative Philosophy.
So, you probably subscribe to the journal,
Journal of Speculative Philosophy,
which I had never heard of until
somebody drew my attention to this.
Who was tested in 1870
by a man who discovered
that this individual claimed
that he had a very strong
memory of his personal experiences.
So, when he was 54 years old in 1870,
he was asked a lot of
questions about his life
going back many, many years back
actually to the age of four years old.
And he responded in every
case to the questions
in two or three seconds.
The test was repeated several days later
and he responded with the same answers
but not using the same words.
That is, he knew what he could remember
but he used different words to say it.
What happened on October 8th, 1828,
Wednesday, it was cloudy
and drizzling and rain.
I carried dinner to my father
where he was getting out coal.
That was 42 years ago.
Let me run down, let's
take April 4th, 1841,
he answered in three seconds.
It was a Sunday, it was rainy and muddy.
General Harrison died that day.
February 2nd, 1856, two-second response.
Saturday it was most awful cold,
it was the coldest day
I ever see in my life.
Records for Iowa, February 4th
indicated the coldest day in 1856.
Now that's the bottom, that's
my interrogation because
all of these are claims that people make
and you could make them up, you know?
What did you do in June 12th, 1993?
And you could, oh, I
went shopping that day.
I had a fight with my
boyfriend or whatever.
(audience laughs)
And I wouldn't know
whether that's true or not.
So, to my limited ability that I had,
I looked up the records
for things that he said
when he said it snowed or it rained.
On the day that he said
it was a heavy snow
that was a heaviest day of
snowing in Iowa that year.
On the day that it rained,
it was within two days
of the date that he gave.
So to the extent that we
can validate these claims,
they appear to be accurate,
he appears to have a phenomenal memory
of his personal experiences,
but not a lot is known about him.
I'm just reporting what was reported
in that rather obscure journal.
Now, I didn't know anything about him,
I had never read that article.
As a matter of fact, that
article was sent to me
by a wag who after we started
publishing our work on
Highly Superior Autobiographical Memory,
essentially he said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"You didn't know about this, you know?"
And he sent me the
article from this journal
that I do not subscribe to, yeah.
(audience laughing)
And I haven't found it on PubMed.
In 2000, a young woman, 32
years old named Jill Price
sent me an email
and it said she had a memory problem
and would like to meet me.
Well, I wrote back to her and said
this is a research institute, not a clinic
but I can direct you to it.
What would you think when somebody said
I have a memory problem, right?
Well she said, "Oh no, no, that's it.
"My memory problem is
that I don't forget."
So, I decided to meet with her.
I really thought that she probably didn't.
I really did think this
was a very strange behavior
but I agreed to meet with her.
When she came since we have never seen any
by like that are tested
I didn't know what to do.
I had been given for
Christmas, this is 2000
and I had been given a coffee table book
which is about this thick
which is newspaper reports for
everyday in the last century.
You may have seen them, they
were around in that time.
And so, all I did was open that book
and asked her questions.
I turned to a page which
was after the age of 13
because she said that's when
she began to have this ability.
And I questioned her
and these were the kinds
of thing that I asked.
I asked about an event.
I said when was there a
major San Diego plane crash.
How many of you remember the plane crash
in September 25th, 1978?
How many of you would
have remembered the date
if I hadn't said that?
All right.
When did the Persian Gulf War start?
Wednesday, January 16, 1991.
And so on down the line.
The one at the bottom I
wanna draw your attention to.
I asked her when was the Iranian
invasion of the US Embassy
and she said November 4th, 1979
and I was looking at the
article right in front of me,
and I said, "Well, you
have it pretty close.
"You're several days off."
And she said, "No, no, no.
"This is the date."
And I said, "Well, it's written
here right in the book."
And she said, "Well, the book is wrong."
(audience laughs)
Well, it turns out that I was looking
at the date of the article it was written
and down in the body of
the article was the true,
the valid time which
is November 4th, 1979.
But it was her assurance
that was important.
"The book was wrong," she said.
Now, we also or I also
asked her about dates.
I gave her a date and she had to tell me
what happened on that date.
August 16th, 1977 Elvis died.
Let's go down November 4th, 1979
and that's right, the Iranian
invasion of US Embassy.
October 5th, 1983 bombing in Beirut.
Northridge earthquake
and Lockerby plane crash.
And so, these are all accurate.
These are her responses
and I'm looking at the book
so I knew the answers but I knew them
because I was looking at them.
Now, we can't take these
statements as being a valid.
As a matter of fact, she
says that she remembers
being in a crib when she was an infant.
Well, I'm not gonna accept that.
We have no way of validating
and besides that, plenty
of people see videos
of themselves in cribs or
pictures of themselves.
And so, that's not gonna do the job,
we have to validate it.
Fortunately, in her case she kept a diary
for many years of her life
and whenever she made a claim
we were able to untie
a little pink ribbon,
it was tied around this
little book that she had
and lots of books, so stacked like that,
opened it up and see if what
she said about it was accurate.
At one time, we asked her to give us
the dates of the last 20 Easters.
How many of you remember
the date of the last Easter?
(audience laughs)
Now, she told us the date
of the last 20 Easters.
She also told us without asking
what she did on each of those dates
and we could check that out
because we're able to
peek into her diaries
and validate some of that information.
Now, I'm gonna show you
some other subjects,
let me, I have to say that
we got a little publicity
inadvertently sort of.
We went on NPR, disguised her name,
but talked about this a little bit
and then a little bit
on newspaper publicity.
We began to get subjects
and by the time 2010 rolled around,
we had five subjects.
Now, they were filmed on 60 Minutes
on December 19th, 2010, that was a Sunday.
(audience laughing)
It's helpful but 60 Minutes
is always on a Sunday,
that's a little clue.
I did, well, I'll go on.
I don't wanna show off anymore.
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna show you clips from
TV programs in which we had this.
The first one is Louise Owen
who is a professional
violinist in New York,
a very high level violinist.
Appears frequently both in groups
and also well solos and is
really a very charming person.
I'll show you her first.
- [Narrator] McGaugh
says this type of memory
is completely new to science
so he and his colleagues have
had to device their own test
like this one on public events.
- October 19th, 1987.
- It was a Monday, that
was the day of the big
stock market crash and the
cellist Jacqueline du Pre
died that day.
- The Berlin Wall falls on what day?
- November 9th, 1989 which was a Thursday.
- Christopher Reeve's
accident occurred on what day?
- [Louise] It was
Saturday, May 27th, 1995.
- And when were the Oscars held in 1999?
- In 1999, Sunday, March 21st.
- Yes, perfect.
- Note that she didn't
say give me a moment,
I'll think about it.
(audience laughing)
She describes it as a Google Search
and when she talks about
it she uses expressions.
She says it's just there,
it just comes up like that
and you can see the ease
with which she did it,
the smile on her face
and the speed of responding
within a second or two,
it's right there.
Let's move back in time now to 1990.
It rained on several days
in January and February.
Can you name the dates on which it rained?
(laughs)
- [Narrator] Believe it or not she could.
- Let's see, it was
slightly rainy and cloudy
on January 14th, 15th.
It was very hot the weekend
of the 27th to 28th, no rain.
- [Narrator] We checked the
official weather records.
- It rained very hard
on Sunday, February 4th.
- [Narrator] And she was right.
- All right, that was 20 years ago
from the time that I asked her.
I was asking her when did
it rain in New York City
20 years ago in January, February
and she nailed everyday.
Now, this is important because
for many of the other
examples that I've shown,
people could memorize.
That is if you set your mind to it
you could memorize thing
and you spend all of your
time memorizing experiences
like learning a list of
words or whatever I suppose.
I chose this example
because it's highly unlikely
unless you wanna challenge me on this,
that she sat around for 20 years saying
I must remember the
days in which it rained
in New York on those two months.
Now we have also, by luck,
found several children
who have this ability
and this is important also because of the
possible interpretation that these people
have the ability because
they spend a lot of time
rehearsing, rehearsing, rehearsing.
Children don't have much time to do that
so I'm gonna show you a couple
of fairly young children
who have ability which is
just as good as our adults.
- Hausler, age 10.
What day of the week was Halloween 2011?
- Monday.
That one I didn't even
have to think about.
- New Year's day 2010.
- A Friday.
- [Woman] Friday.
- I remember that because I was up
all night at the Blues game.
- That's when Jake was 6.
He lives in Saint Louis, loves sports
and he is in most respects,
a typical 10-year old.
What happened related to school
on January 30th, 2013?
- That day I'm pretty sure.
Oh wait, that's a trick question.
No school that day.
(audience laughing)
There's a lightning storm that one night.
I'm like yeah, we didn't
have school that day.
- [James] 7th 2012, you know
what day of the week that was?
- That was a Sunday.
- [James] You're right.
- [Narrator] There is exactly
one child in the world
other than Jake who's
been identified so far
with this ability,
11-year old Tyler Hickenbottom.
And in a fortuitous coincidence,
Tyler happens to be an identical twin.
He and his brother, Chad,
share the same genes.
- Yeah, I think I might
have worn an orange shirt.
- [Narrator] But surprisingly
not the same memory.
- No, it was obviously on 2012 when.
(audience laughing)
- Life can be tough.
This is very interesting.
We are doing genetic studies now,
we're collaborating in genetic studies
and the first thing we wanna find out is
are they really identical twins.
Their parents claim that they are
and we're going to recheck that.
Once again, the reason for
the interest in children
is because we wanna find out
the age at which this is
first recognized by children.
We have younger children
now who are 10 years old
who have the ability going
back to the age of five,
and a little bit earlier than that.
This is not an ability which
is acquired later in life,
it appears fairly early on.
How early, we don't yet know.
Now here is a distribution
of the ability of people
who have what we call HSAM
or highly superior autobiographical memory
and on the right in the white and blue
you see the distribution
of the percent correct
on a 30 question quiz of the kind
that I've already talked about
ranging from let's say 35%
correct up to 75% correct.
On the left in orange you see controls,
age and sex match controls
and you can see that this is not,
this ability is not the end of,
extreme end of a normal distribution,
it is a different distribution.
Also you can see some white
on the left mixed with the orange.
These are people who claim
that they have the ability
and were just like controls.
If you look on the far left
there are four people who claim
they have the ability and
they are worse than controls.
(audience laughing)
We gave the best of those
a 10 Dates Quiz asking
for 10 dates that we
selected a day of the week,
a verifiable event that
happened on that day.
An autobiographical event
which we did not check
but they claimed it was autobiographical.
Now what you can see is
in the blue are the people
that have this ability
and the orange are us
and you can see that they
get about 14% correct
on day of the week which is
one out of seven by the way.
(audience laughing)
They have no verifiable event and see.
So you see they are quite different.
We also gave them
autobiographical memory test
and here we validated,
we ask them first day at university,
first day at elementary school,
so on, down the list that you can see.
And we thankfully got all of
the data, support all of that.
Our HSAM subjects gave
145 verified details,
controls gave a total of 24 details
which we did not bother to verify.
(audience laughs)
All right, here are some characteristics.
These folks are highly accurate
in autobiographical remembering.
They are not at all exceptional
in learning and laboratory tests.
We've done a lot of experimental
psychology types of test with them
and they're absolutely on average normal.
One thing that is of interest,
they also show signs of compulsiveness
and they show some
differences in brain regions,
so I'll show you quickly here.
Here's the region of uncinate fasciculus
which is a fiber pathway that goes
from the temporal lobe
up to the frontal lobes.
And this is more obvious
in MRI, structural MRI.
It's also a region that
is found to be deficient
in people who have highly
deficient autobiographical memory.
The parahippocampal gyrus
which is not too much of a surprise
because that region has
been implicated in memory
and also found in people
who have strong memory of other kinds.
And the lentiform nucleus which is in the
region of the, we caught
a nucleus which has
some studies have shown to be significant,
significantly observed in people who have
obsessive compulsive disorder.
And all of our people score highly
on obsessive compulsive test
and they also display
obsessiveness, germ avoidance
and other things.
I have the time I could tell you
some very interesting things
about what they avoid.
Here's some important questions.
First, what insights can
we learn about memory?
Is it strong storage of information
or is it exceptional retrieval?
We don't think it's simply
exceptional retrieval
because it's exceptional retrieval
of their own autobiographical experiences,
not of other things.
We even did an experiment in which we
gave them some information
and then they had a discussion
with the experimenter
and they were tested later on.
They remembered everything that they said
and nothing that the experimenter said.
(audience laughs)
So, it is all about them.
Is there involvement of emotional arousal?
Well, that's what I do for a living.
That's my main research
and yet we have plenty of examples
of them remembering pretty banal things.
You saw the list that I showed you.
My favorite example is our first subject.
I asked her if she knew
who Bing Crosby was
and she said yes.
She would have been very young,
maybe in her teenage years
I said, "You know what happened to him?"
And she said, "Oh yes, he died
on a golf course in Spain."
And she gave me the date and the day.
And I said, "How did you know that?"
She said, "Well, my mother was
driving me to a soccer game
"and the news came on over the radio."
And she remembers that to this day.
Is there a genetic basis?
We're studying that at the
present time, we don't know.
Neurobiological implications?
I think this is the most important one
and this has been touched
on already in the symposium.
These individuals not
only can give us clues
to understanding how their brain works
in order to produce this really
phenomenal memory ability
but by understanding the
neural underpinnings of this
we can get a greater understanding
of how the brain processes memory,
new insights can come
from this ultimately.
And then finally, why
is this ability so rare?
If memory is so important
I started off by saying
it's our most important ability.
Why is it that we are
so poor in what we do
and in a certain way they are better?
William James said,
"Forgetting is as important
"a function as recollecting.
"If we remembered everything we should be
"on most occasions as ill off
"as if we remembered nothing."
These people remember an awful
lot about in a way nothing,
just trivial events they
remember quite well.
They are unremarkable in other respects.
If they were here in the room
and there may be several people here,
if you didn't ask memory questions
you would not be able to identify them.
They remember for a long period of time
and we need to find out
and our research will
continue to do that, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- There's a long history
writing about Savant's
who emerged in childhood
and I'm gonna talk about
a slightly different syndrome.
My friend Allan Snyder
in Australia suggested
this be called Acquired Savantism.
And so, these are people who did not have
artistic abilities or talents who
in the setting of
neurodegenerative diseases
have acquired new artistic abilities,
and this is a group that
I lead in San Francisco.
And almost everybody in that audience
has helped me in some way in this work.
We know a lot about art
in the brain from lesions
whether it's brain tumors,
strokes, brain trauma
and there are certain
themes that have emerged.
One is that the right
posterior parts of the brain,
parietal lobe in particular
are essentially for the ability to copy,
and probably along with
the right temporal lobe
conjure up images that we wanna
put on a piece of a paper.
The smallest lesion in that brain area
will devastate the ability to copy
not as bad as Dan's artwork
but along that spectrum.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, okay.
A little bit less known,
I'm gonna touch on this today about the
left side of the brain
but in general the senses that symbolic,
linguistic, conceptual aspects of art
are associated with left hemisphere.
And with the injury to
that part of the brain
there is a theme in the
literature of preservation
of the ability to copy.
I began to study this not
because I thought about it
because it sort of ran into me
in the study of patients that I've seen
with neurodegenerative disease.
And I was taught going
into my fellowship that
degenerative diseases
hit the brain diffusely.
You could learn nothing about
the functions of the brain
from studying neurodegenerative diseases
but I think we've known really
since the time of Pick and Alzheimer that
we have two major presenile
neurodegenerative conditions.
One that affects the
front part of the brain
often begins in the fronto-insular
and sometimes anterior temporal
lobes, that's shown in blue.
These are disorders that are called
frontotemporal dementias.
They have a lack of Alzheimer pathology,
no plaques or tangles.
Then Alzheimer's usually
posteriorly predominant disease
that affects the hippocampus.
So, very different anatomy
and very different sorts of syndromes
that we see in the setting of these two
distinctive neurodegenerative conditions.
There's been a lot written about
art and Alzheimer's disease.
Many people get quite a
bit of pleasure working in
with art therapists with
Alzheimer's disease.
And I think what these
disorders tell you is that
your art is influenced
by the part of the brain
that is injured.
Because Alzheimer's disease hits the
posterior temporal parietal regions,
sometimes worse on the
right than the left,
sometimes left worse than the right.
You lose precision,
there tends to be visuospatial difficulty
but some things remain,
ability to perceive color,
simple shapes, this is one
of my patient's painting.
This is Megan Fox.
I think quite a beautiful piece,
a very nice use of color
I think very typical of what we see
in the setting of Alzheimer's disease.
And of course, fine
artists like de Kooning,
William Utermohlen were
profoundly disrupted
in their ability to produce
images of complex phases,
complex shape and were
left with very simple,
simple forms like this.
In frontotemporal dementia
there's a different sort of story
and this is a paper we wrote in 1998.
Focused on the emergence
of new artistic skills
after the disease onset.
The theme was that visual
creativity was more common
when the anterior temporal lobes
or the left frontal lobe was where
the focal degeneration began.
These are often called
primary progressive aphasias
because they affect language
but remarkably in some individuals,
we see an emergence of visual creativity.
Wrote about that in 1998.
I didn't understand the
mechanism very well.
Starting to understand the circuitry
that we think emerges
in the setting of this
loss of function in the
dominant hemisphere.
This was a patient, Jack,
that got me interested in this story.
He was a banker, he
lived in Santa Barbara.
They did a special on him on ABC News
and Jack had never had the
slightest interest in art.
In the 1980s his wife
died, he became depressed,
he started working with an art therapist
and started painting.
What I learned about Jack
is he painted repetitively,
he did many of the pictures that I saw
over and over again.
This compulsive need to paint
I think was one of the
reasons that his painting
was so interesting and successful.
This is I think one of his masterpieces.
When I saw him around 1995,
Jack was obsessed with painting
profoundly aphasic head loss.
Many of the words, particularly nouns.
He drew this parrot that
he remembered from Hawaii
yet couldn't tell me
what this painting was.
Obsessed with the colors
purple and yellow.
Like many of these
patients completely unable
to get him to describe the art of creating
or why he did it.
The phrases I heard
over and over again was
yellow and purple wave over me.
He became obsessed with painting.
He painted purple things and yellow things
over and over again.
Progressively lost social
skills and language.
Visually profoundly preoccupied.
Jack used to walk the
streets of Santa Barbara
with his caretaker looking for coins.
When I visited him in Santa Barbara
I was sitting at the table,
immediately he says, "It's raining."
Now he had an uncanny I think
ability to focus visually.
Jack produced these series of paintings.
This is a slightly later one.
I think very fauvist in style.
You can see an interesting strategy
where the sail is both the
background and the sail.
Losing some of the precision that he had
I think is the disease that creeps
into the parietal lobes more posteriorly.
A slightly later piece where he is really
losing the ability in the
way an Alzheimer patient
might paint precisely.
Again that theme of purple
and yellow, Jack's obsession.
And then finally one of the
last pieces he ever did,
I think quite whimsical,
beautiful picture of a man.
As he lost the ability to paint
this was replaced by the
compulsion to brush his teeth.
He did this over and over again
and as we learned later,
Jack had a form of
frontotemporal dementia,
very interesting form that has
been called semantic dementia
or semantic variant of
primary progressive aphasia.
It's a subtype of frontotemporal dementia.
It was what Pick described in 1892.
It affects predominantly the
two anterior temporal lobes.
When it affects the left side
which most of my artists
come from this group
you lose your knowledge about words.
You lose your knowledge eventually
about things in the world.
Unlike Alzheimer's disease,
the naming deficit
isn't improved by clues.
They don't know what that word means.
The anatomy is very focal.
I think as these individuals lose function
in the amygdala anterior temporal lobes
orbital frontal cortex,
there's disinhibition,
progressive language disturbance
but often visuospatial
skills are profoundly spared.
These are people whose only
point on a cognitive test
is drawing a complex visual figure.
This is something that is often
spared in these individuals
and in a subgroup there is a new emergence
of interest in painting and
increased visual creativity.
I always thought this was first
described by a neurologist
but on a trip to Colombia around 2006
I was reading A Hundred Years of Solitude
by Gabriel Garcia Marquez
and I came across his description.
The first description of semantic dementia
I think in the literature.
It's the town of Macondo,
people are dying of a sleeping sickness
and he describes what happens to them.
He discovered he had trouble remembering
every object in the laboratory.
He didn't know what they were.
He marked them with their respective names
so that all he had to do
was read the inscription
in order to identify them.
This is the cow.
She must be milk every morning
so that she will produce milk,
and the milk must be boiled
in order to be mixed with coffee.
A gorgeous description.
They went on living in a
reality that was slipping away
momentarily captured by words
but which would escape irremediably
when they forgot the
values of written letters.
Around the time that I
discovered this piece
from Gabriel Garcia Marquez,
we had a patient very much
like the villager in Macondo.
This is my patient Bob who
like many of these individuals
know that they're losing words,
know that they're losing
knowledge about facts
in their world.
And you can see here just like
Garcia Marquez' description
he's putting down these names,
these words, compulsively, repetitively,
Foley catheter, endocarditis.
He knows that his world is slipping away
just in the way Gabriel
Garcia Marquez described it.
I don't think and be
glad to talk about this
with anyone online, offline,
that Marquez actually saw a
case of semantic dementia.
I think he was writing
about his own writer's block
and I think this is what he
conceptualized at the time.
We couldn't resist, this is Bob's
who drew a cow quite beautifully.
His elephant I think rather whimsical.
Certainly better than Dan and I could do
I think in the copy so, yeah.
(audience laughs)
This is a degenerative disease.
The concepts for these
animals often nouns first,
verbs relatively spared.
Look like they come out of evolution.
I appreciated the picture
of Darwin earlier.
The dog looks a little bit like a cat.
It looks like some features of a cow
as similarly the cat
has features of the dog.
The fish to me looks
very much like a penguin
but I think as you're watching
this patient with semantic dementia
lose their conceptual knowledge around
what distinctive animals really are.
And of course if you don't
know what an animal is
you don't know what color to give it.
We asked this patient to draw the frog
and put the color in.
He drew a pink frog, not the
green one which he should.
This is my latest favorite set of pieces.
This is gentleman who we're gonna describe
for the journal JAMA.
He became obsessed with welding.
He was not an artist.
This is his bird and you can see
it has got that same
quality of a mixed metaphor.
The bird has features of an insect
and I think this really has taught me that
what an artist does is
put down on a canvas
the way that they see the world, okay.
So, just a couple conclusion points.
Our poet laureate Kay
Ryan from Marin County
has taught us at the UCSF about
the neuroscientist Emily Dickinson.
And I think Emily Dickinson
had a very modern way
of thinking about the brain.
And so when I was thinking
about these patients
I came across this poem by her
and I think she was
interested in moral decay
but this is really the decay
of neurodegenerative diseases
as we understand it in 2017.
Crumbling or the dementia
is not an instant act
and we now know probably 20 years
before we see a patient
with one of these diseases
that the degenerative process has begun.
A fundamental pause,
dilapidation's processes
are organized decays.
Totally contradicts the idea that the
dementias hit the brain diffusely.
These are organized decays
in very specific circuits.
Other circuits are spared.
'Tis first a Cobweb on the Soul,
this is the misfolded
protein that Rusty Gage,
Dan Geschwind talk and write about.
Cuticle of Dust, a Borer in the Axis,
an Elemental Rust.
Ruin is formal, Devil's
work, consecutive and slow.
Fail in an instant, no man did,
slipping or the dementing
process is Crash's law.
We see the crash but I think
what these artists have told me is that
there is a period when
this process is beginning
where certain parts of the brain
may be particularly
immune to the degenerative process.
They are spared and
possibly begin to remodel
and we've written a little bit about this
describing an artist named Ann Adams.
The conclusion is it's I think a beautiful
but also a very sad story.
Artistic creativity may emerge
with left hemisphere dysfunction.
I think we have some data
from the artist Ann Adams
that there is rewiring of right
posterior parietal regions.
Very area that Karen Berman showed as
probably dysfunctional and
kids with Williams syndrome.
Insights into the degenerative
process suggest that
sometimes a new strength may herald
the degenerative process
but I think understanding
people's strengths
are critical for diagnosis and care.
And I think also this gives us insight
into our humanity and almost
everyone has touched on this.
Brain assymetry is at
the core of our strengths
but also the core of our weaknesses,
so, thank you.
(audience clapping)
- People with synaesthesia
experience the ordinary world
in quite extraordinary ways.
For some people when they
look at letters on a page
each letter might have
its own distinctive color
which either appears in
the synaesthete's mind eye
or is perhaps projected on to the page
on top of the regular text.
Further, synaesthete's time
and the calendar for example
or numbers are seen visuospatially
as kind of an undulating landscape.
And this might serve as a memory aid.
For example, we see it
in the case of Jill Price
that was presented earlier.
Not only has she got fantastic
autobiographical memory
she perceives the years
in terms of her own
internal landscape of time.
This is one of my first
case studies of synaesthesia
and this is a man who tastes words.
As he's listening to me speaking now
each word might have its own
distinct flavor on his mouth
and this is his representation
of the London Tube map, the Underground.
And words for him might taste
of celery or sausage meat.
He grew up in Britain in the 1960s
where this was your quintessential
kind of diet growing up.
He's internalized this
in his synaesthesia.
One of the first case studies
that points to extraordinary
ability in synaesthesia
is this book by Luria called
The Mind of A Mnemonist
and this is somebody who's described
as having an infinite memory
who never forgets things,
who can remember sequences
of abstract syllables
that are presented to him
and then recalls them years later.
And also has phenomenal
autobiographical memory as well.
As well as having amazing memory,
he also had various kinds of synaesthesia
so numbers would elicit colors.
The sound of somebody's voice
would have both colors, taste and touch.
He had a multiplicity of
different kinds of synaesthesia.
And this is a case that
we already heard about
who has both synaesthesia
and Asperger syndrome,
high functioning autism.
Daniel could recite pi
to 20,000 decimal places,
a feat which takes around five hours
just to say the digits aloud.
But what he's doing
when he's recalling them
is also extraordinary
because for him the digits
is not just a verbal string,
it's a visuospatial
string that he reads off
in his mind's eye.
And this is his representation
of the first 20 digits of pi.
For him each digit has
its own particular color
and its own particular texture
and its own position in the sequence
that he reads off as he's
recollecting the sequence.
These are extraordinary cases,
is synaesthesia in general
linked to enhanced memory
and if so why might this be?
What we know about
synaesthetes is that they have
differences in their brain
although these aren't well-characterized,
it's more gray matter and more
white matter organization.
At least patchy within some regions.
One possibility is that
you could use synaesthesia
as a kind of a memory aid.
If you see words spelled out
that it might help you to remember them.
You're using your synaesthesia
as a kind of cognitive tool.
The other possibility is that it's
something about the
brain changes themselves
that give rise not only to synaesthesia
but also give rise to other
particular cognitive phenotypes
such as enhanced memory
and allowed you in favor of this
to present various lines of evidence.
First of all if we look
at the memory ability
of people with synaesthesia,
these are people who experience
words and letters as colored
and we would give them a
standard recognition memory test
in which we present them with a sequence
of say 30 words to remember.
And then we a test we
present them with 60 words,
half of which they saw before
and half of which they didn't.
And we made them visually
similar to try and confuse them
and of course they were
presented in a random order
not consecutively like this.
But at the end we also ask what strategy
did they use for memorizing them.
And actually when you back sort people
by the kind of strategy they have
yes, these kind of semantic associations
have a best strategy
but it doesn't make any
difference what strategy you use.
If you're a synaesthete you do better
on this particular test.
Another way of doing it with another group
is that you actually give them a strategy,
so one is that you can process it deeply.
You make semantic judgements about words
such as whether it's living
and the other words you
process it shallowly.
You ask about the letters in the word.
And again, whether or not you process it
shallowly or deeply,
synaesthetes have better
memory for words here
and they produce fewer false alarms,
misrecognitions of them.
Here these are verbal stimuli
that for these people elicit colors.
What about if you look at
nonverbal visual stimuli?
These are some of the kinds
of stimuli that we presented.
Again here we would have scenes
so we would present them with say
a series of 30 scenes and then a test,
we'd present them with the same scenes
and ones that are very similar
just a little bit different.
Or also fractals of very abstract images
which people find very hard,
they're very hard to recode verbally
or in any other particular way.
Or similarly you can have
regular colored scenes
but you can manipulate them in some way.
You can reverse it, you can
flip the color for example
or you can make objects
appear or disappear.
This is again a difficult memory test.
What we find here is that
synaesthetes outperform controls.
Here what we've got is effect size.
This is a measure of
the relative advantage
of synaesthetes over controls.
Typically they have medium effect sizes
but actually they do much
better for visual material
over verbal material
even though the visual
material is not triggering
any extra experiences for these people.
They describe thinking in visual images.
For them they think in very sensory ways
remembering events as like
reliving it in your mind's eye.
And for some things they
do particularly well.
Notice for the fractals
that's actually one of their best things
and these are very hard for
people typically to remember.
They can hold on to
visual patterns very well.
What I would argue here is that
synaesthesia is linked to enhanced memory
but although you might sometimes use
synaesthesia as a memory aid,
it's probably something more fundamental
in terms of the way that
their brain is wired,
in terms of holding on to
visual and sensory information
for example in this stimuli.
What you'll also see in these studies
is that synaesthetes do
well on lab test on memory
but actually their memory
isn't so phenomenal
that they're going to produce
jaw-dropping feats at a party.
And some of my colleagues have said
well, hang on, this means
that these exceptional cases
that we've talked about,
they're anomalies.
These are the outliers.
Something different must
be going on in these cases.
And I've kind of toyed with this idea
but actually we don't
necessarily need to look
for a different explanation
for those who have
a small upward shift and for
those who have a large one.
And all we have to do is just think about
the normal distribution.
Here what you've got is a shift of
half a standard deviation.
This is the low end of
the medium effect size.
Very much the conservative
end of what I presented.
The synaesthetes are
here in the light blue
and what you can do is you can slice up
these normal distribution and ask
how many people lie in each of these ones.
Between naught and one standard deviations
you'll find 38% of synaesthetes
and 34% of control.
A ratio that favors the synaesthetes.
But as you move up,
in fact what you find
is that it's nonlinear.
The synaesthetes are very much
overrepresented at the extremes here.
And if you exceed this, so if you go up to
an effect size of 0.8 which
again is not unrealistic
given some of the data I presented,
you see again that it goes
up quite astonishingly
the amount of synaesthetes
that you would expect at the high end.
If you put it another way
if you were to give me a thousand people
and you were to rank
them in terms of their
memory ability from left to right,
and you ask me can I find a synaesthete
amongst that distribution,
where would I look?
Well, I could look where the mean is
because that's where most
of the synaesthetes are numerically.
But the problem with that
is that you've also got
an awful lot of non-synaesthetes
who will be performing at that level.
The best place to look is actually
at the 1,000th person on the right
and statistically that is the person
most likely to have synaesthesia,
and you don't need to do the
experiment, it's just maths.
But the closest experiment we've done
is to take a group of people who perform
in memory championships.
There are world rankings for
doing bizarre things like
remembering the order of a pack of cards
in 35 seconds and so on.
And we were able to test
18 of these memory athletes
and we checked using a valid measure
of Grapheme-color synaesthesia,
the standard one in the literature
and showed that they, synaesthetes
are very significantly
overrepresented within this group.
The prevalence of Grapheme-color
synaesthesia is 1% to 2%.
Other types of synaesthesia push it up
and we had a group of controls that we
tried to select in a similar way.
We've heard a little bit
about the relationship
between synaesthesia and autism
and I came to this quite skeptical.
Why would these two very
different things be related?
But they are related.
Simon Baron-Cohen and a group in Germany
were the first people to actually show
that there's an increased incidence of
synaesthesia and autism.
So they took a group of people with autism
and looked for synaesthesia.
We also did these ourselves
but amongst the autistic people
we looked to those people who have
savant trait and those who don't.
These were all high functioning people
with autism by the way
so they're not at the low end
of intellectual disability.
What we have here, both of
these groups on the left
have a clinical diagnosis of autism
but some of the autistic
people are reporting
savant abilities and this
includes things like perfect pitch
or calendar calculation.
And these people here are far more likely
to have synaesthesia than
the kind of garden-variety
of people with a diagnosis of autism.
It is linked to autism
but it seems to be linked
to special abilities.
As well as looking for synaesthetic traits
amongst people with autism
you can look for autistic traits
amongst people with synaesthesia.
One of the things that we did is
that we took a standard
questionnaire measure of autism
that has 50 questions,
and the questions are
divided into five subscales,
so 10 questions in each.
Four of the subscales actually
ask about difficulties.
Things like social skills
which people with autism find hard.
But there's one subscale
that asks about abilities
and that's attention to detail.
Here this particular
question is reverse coded.
People with autism are very good
at finding the proverbial
needle in a haystack.
They do very good at where's
Waldo kind of puzzles,
detecting parts and wholes and so on.
They do good at this.
If we give this to a group of synaesthetes
again what we find, so this
is a score from naught to 50.
Controls are about 18, synaesthetes
are raised significantly.
They form quite considerably below the
average of an autistic person.
But actually even this shift,
what this means if you model
the tail end of the distribution
is that you would expect
at least twice as many
synaesthetes to be overrepresented
in the tail than that.
These small shifts can have
large effects of the tail
is one of my take home messages.
Here these are the five subscales
and it looks complicated but it isn't.
In the gray bar we got
our group with autism.
High score means that
you're high on the spectrum.
In blue you've got your synaesthetes
and in orange you've got your controls.
This is social skills here.
What we can see is that
for four out of five
of this particular thing,
the synaesthetes are
indistinguishable from the controls.
They're a little bit above them.
But for one out of five,
the synaesthetes are indistinguishable
from people with autism,
and this is in the attention
to detail subscale.
We subsequently confirmed that using
what's called a change blindness paradigm
where you have to note the small changes
in scenes that are flickering.
Synaesthesia or sorry,
autism has been defined
in terms of these impairments
but in the most recent
psychiatric definition
they added sensory symptom
and this was sensory hypersensitivity
and also maybe hyposensitivities.
Some of the things might
be finding bright lights
particularly aversive or giving
you a headache and so on.
And people have developed
various measures of this.
Again, initially using a questionnaire.
This is the one that we used
the Glasgow sensory questionnaire.
And what we find here is that synaesthetes
are significantly above controls
and numerically similar to people
with autism on this measure
despite actually not having
many of the classic signs
of being autistic.
We looked at this in more detail.
Most of the people we've looked at
are these people with
Grapheme-color synaesthesia
because we have very obvious ways
of verifying this in the lab.
But we can also look at the presence of
other kind of synaesthesia.
Those people who see time for example
in this kind of spatial calendars.
People who have tastes or
flavors in their mouth,
people who experience words spelled out
as they listen to speech.
Some people see it like ticker tape
or having visual experiences to music.
And what we can do in effect is we can
take people and we just say
how many of these have you got?
And actually synaesthetes
were asked this question often
about three or four years ago
when they first volunteered
and we kept a database
of that information.
This is what we find in
terms of sensory sensitivity.
We have a very clear dose effect between
how many types of
synaesthesia somebody has
and how much they report
sensory sensitivity on this measure.
This is where people with autism are,
if you've got zero types of synaesthesia
you're our control group.
These are people with
one, two, three and four.
You can't read this at the bottom
but these are just different
combinations of that five
but you don't need to read it.
If you have three types of synaesthesia
that is your level of sensory
sensitivity on this measure.
And this is the proportion
of people in these groups
who are the high end
of the autism spectrum.
People with autism on this measure
typically have a score of 32 or above.
And what you can see is that
it grows up dramatically
with the more types of
synaesthesia you have.
There is a clear relationship
between synaesthesia and
autism but it's complex
and it's to do with the nature of
how synaesthetic your brain is.
To summarize, what I would say is that
synaesthesia is linked
to certain abilities.
It's linked to enhanced memory.
It's also linked to some
of the traits of autism.
It's linked to sensory sensitivity
which I'm not sure whether that's
a positive or negative trait.
It's normally cast in
terms of a negative trait
but whether or not that has particular,
whether it is linked to
either abilities I don't know.
Attention to detail is a clear ability
that is probably driving some
of these savant abilities
to notice patterns, to notice details
in their sensory world.
Although synaesthetes
don't necessarily present
with the triad of impairments
that classically define autism,
what seems to happen is
that you have an increased
vulnerability of getting that.
In a way you buy in to having
the advantages of autism
but the danger is that
you are more susceptible
to getting the negative traits as well.
It's almost as if
synaesthetes are occupying
a very interesting cognitive niche
where they're sliding up the
autistic scale a little bit
and getting some of the benefits
but they're not falling
over the cliff edge.
But you stand a risk
of doing that of course
just by moving up that
particular genetic niche.
To conclude, synaesthesia is linked
to basic difference in brain function.
We don't fully understand
what those differences are
but my best guess is that
it's to do with differences
in plasticity, in holding
on particularly to
sensory information over time.
And also to sensory sensitivity
both subjectively and probably again
in terms of cognitive processing.
Many of these traits seem to be shared
with the positive features of autism.
So abilities, savant's
characteristics and so on.
Synaesthesia is linked to
cognitive enhancements in memory
but again, it doesn't seem that
synaesthesia is just simply
a mnemonic device or a cognitive tool.
Some people do use their
synaesthesia in that way
but it seems to be a deeper connection
between synaesthesia and
cognitive enhancement.
And I guess in terms of
a more general conclusion
for this symposium is an
even medium-sized effect,
so the fact that
synaesthetes are shifted up
by a medium-sized effect means
it has profound consequences at the tail
that you really can
overrepresent things at the tail
because of the way that these
normal distributions go.
It might be that even though
most synaesthetes aren't exceptional,
actually there's something
about synaesthesia
that is really kind of driving things
at that high tail end in the
exceptional ability zone.
Thank you very much for your time.
These are my collaborators
and these are some famous synaesthetes
none of whom I've worked with.
(audience laughs)
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)